Philip Zimbardo
to be here thank you for coming all the
way from from America
it's what we saw here was what you
described as the Lucifer effect in your
in your book yeah it's it's an
experiment with twenty four healthy
students yes locked up in the basement
yes
pretending to be prisoners and guards
what did what did you want to prove what
why did you do this well it's really
more like a Greek tragedy we wanted to
ask the question what happens if you
take people all of whom are good normal
healthy college students intelligent we
gave them personality tests we picked
only the most normal physically healthy
and we put them in a bad place and the
idea is does the goodness of people
dominate the bad place or does the bad
situation come to corrupt the good
people and the sad answer was the latter
how soon could you see Effects of them
being together like this
it was after 36 hours on the first day
nothing happened
because these are students didn't
remember this is 1972 this is the time
everybody's a hippie everybody's
anti-war activist civil rights activists
feminist movement is starting so in the
end this is the era of hair everybody's
has hair
you know don't trust anybody over 30 so
that's all the students come from that
and we asked them before if you have a
choice to be a prisoner guard whichever
you choose it also I don't want to be a
guard that's a big but we so we randomly
assign them with a clip of the coin you
be a guard you be a prisoner you'll be a
guard you'll be a prisoner and so the
first day the boys who addressed like
guards in military and they felt awkward
make they're saying oh no laughing and I
was going to end the study after the
first day but then the next morning the
prisoners rebelled they locked
themselves in the cell they took
everybody had to wear a number that we
took away the name they ripped off their
number they're cursing the guards and
then the guard said these are dangerous
prisoners and that changed everything so
psychologically they were not other
students they were dangerous prisoners
and they said we have to crush the
rebellion and at that point the dynamic
change so who what do they do how do
this
to behave they stripped them naked and
humiliate them you know make it look
small penis and and and then they
cleaned the toilet bowls out with their
bare hands each day each hour they make
the prisoners do more and more
humiliating self degradation things and
from a psychological point of view how
do you how do you analyze this what's
the well let's see the point the lesson
in this study is when we're trying to
understand human behavior the
traditional way is to focus on what's
inside the person the effective
character genes and that's psychiatry
most of psychology but really it's the
legal system it's there are religious
system what I say is we have ignored
what's outside of the person so this
study is part of other research that
says we have to be sensitive to the
power of the situation the way we
address the role we're playing whether
we're alone with other people whether we
have ID
we're anonymous or identifiable I also
wonder because you were a part of this
what happened to you in this process
well see when situations transform good
people it's it's gradual so you never
notice I was the prison superintendent
that's the role I played and as prison
super ten I'm in charge of logistics on
my door it said prison superintendent
and everybody treated me like a prison
superintendent and that's what I became
so this affected your behavior well yeah
if you're if you are a superintendent
you care about the guards and you care
about your institution you don't really
care about prisoners and so when I
looked out and saw prison is suffering I
didn't see suffering I said oh the
guards are doing their ten o'clock
toilet run it was a checkmark on a scale
and so what I did I prevented the guards
from using physical force I didn't
prevent them from using psychological
force I just ignored it said the guards
are doing their job and so I don't know
what would have happened if the
experiment went for two weeks if it had
not if I had not been forced to end it
early why were you forced well it's
really an interesting story halfway
through I was going to in I had
prepare to invite graduate students and
young faculty to come down interview
everybody the guards the prisoners and
the staff to see how the study was going
and one of the people who came down the
first one came down was a young woman
who I just started dating she had been a
student of mine had just graduated
Stanford was going to it Berkeley and
she comes down and I say hey Chris look
at this and she looks out she sees the
guards putting bags over the prisoners
head chaining the legs together
having them line up and and yelling and
cursing at them I look up and I check
mark oh ten o'clock toilet run I said
you see she starts crying he said what's
the matter with you
she said it's it's terrible what you are
doing for those boys they're not prisons
in that course they're boys and you are
responsible if she runs out and I run
out they said what's wrong with you what
kind of psychologists are you you know
that's what's wrong with women there's
two sauce and she said wait a minute she
said I don't know who you are she said I
thought you were a caring loving person
I don't know who this person is you know
and essentially it's like a double slap
in the face I said oh my god you're
right because you couldn't see it
yourself I couldn't see it because that
happened a little bit it's hour by hour
it's they have today that that I became
the role yeah exactly the same thing yes
and you were actually an expert witness
in in in the the case about Abu Ghraib
see again at the prison in Iraq so again
here's American soldiers men and women
we see the same pictures even worse and
of course the Bush administration in the
military said oh no no don't blame the
system these are bad apples I said no no
it's exactly like the Stanford Prison
study it's good American soldiers put in
a bad barrel in in Iraq in this prison
and so I became an expert witness for
one of the guards and I studied that and
that's what I write in my book the loser
effect it's exactly the same the
military created this dungeon where they
got encourage the soldiers to break the
prisoners so they could get information
and then they never gave them
supervision nobody ever went down no
officer went down to the dungeon at
night so all the guards and on the night
shift did bad things
no God on the day shift did bad things
that's the power of the situation thank
you so much Chris thank you thank you
please welcome from Chicago Corelli